[Applaudissements]
merci
j'ai changé mes frères et soeurs
qu'avant
bah moi dans une bibliothèque je veux
partir mais qui avec julie raynaud
plutôt avec jules emmanuel à la
productrice bah oui mais tu tenu avant
le tour
oui il était dans les livres quand il
est allé me donnait de racket c'est pas
ça l'est moins c'est que j'ai écrit
alors vous êtes qui dit
[Rires]
eh bien avec nous comme oui mesdames où
la glace est la limite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
demande de répondre sans détour
est-ce que
pendant que vous et tire en couple vous
avez eu des pensées impures pour une
autre femme où tout être vivant
ils sont représentés la voilà voilà
[Musique]
elle ne paie pas une guerre les deux
contre les riches et arrêter de l'exqi
league europa
[Musique]
les
je serai peut-être colère parce que non
ça devant bernard mais j'étais pas très
enthousiaste à l'idée de venir au monde
donc ils sont un peu tirés des jeux
techniques toit sans oreilles décollées
ce n'est pas eric naulleau voilà c'est
ça je vous dis dans ma vie j'ai du
boulot
donc ça n'a pas fait très beau comme ça
je vais essayer et refaire tout
ouais je leur reproche je suis pas le
seul dans cette émission a jamais
vouloir se déguiser en même temps c'est
pas comme si les ja toujours à 10 comme
un truc là je n'ai pas un reproche c'est
un regret j'aurais dû garder tous les
papiers qui m'a fait passer parce qu'il
y en a qui sont exclues commandant du
fort embarrassante année je reproche à
jean michel mr d'inventer ses anecdotes
oui et que ces anecdotes sont à peu près
aussi fausse que ses cheveux
est-ce que ce soir pouvait dire parce
qu'on est pressé là on à valence ton
poste important à machecoul dit est ce
que ce soir vous pouvez le dire c'est
une émission d'intello était pas
chroniqueur
alors oui je retire ce que j'ai
les excuses à glisser gentiment georges
apprécié le geste voilà et s'il fait un
pas vers moi donc je vais faire un pas
vers la bravo voilà et donc j'aime bien
les bruits mettre un coup de boule
[Applaudissements]